it's so nice to finally meet you and I  usually date people I meet on the  Internet his vegan food is rising ly  flavorful I wish I had more time to go  to museums I just I love art so much I'm  a casual gamer I like videogames but  they're not my life my degree is a  little unorthodox but it has practical  applications it was mutual  what I'm really looking for it's a guy  with a sense of humor oh yeah I was in a  frat but it wasn't like a frat friend  you know I love my job  it gives me lots of time to work on my  art I'm not a big drinker  I moved on I haven't thought about her  in weeks  oh the fedora it's mostly ironic I do  all my own cooking I don't even know in  a microwave don't usually sweat this  much that's great uh I'll text you  tomorrow  fool what do I care if she's dating a  doctor ha ha ha just I'm just happy  she's happy